hello and welcome i'm dave elliott
global product lead for storage products
here at Google I'm a former backup admin
and spent most of my career in storage
and backup over the last four years I've
been helping Google shaped its cloud
storage offering and today we're here to
talk about the economics of tape versus
cloud and what the real costs are
associated with each so a few things
before we get started first this is a
construct or a discussion right it's a
hopefully will provide a way for you to
think about the cost of tape and cloud
and a little bit of a dialogue for you
and your team it's not formal it's not
highly produced it's probably wrong in a
lot of areas second thing tape isn't
going away anytime soon right so there's
lots of significant sunk costs and tape
and real benefits to take really the
question is the question we're trying to
answer today or the dialog rabbit today
is what's changing right there's a
changing landscape is changing
technology changing requirements and
there's changing possibilities a third
is frankly unbiased right I work with
tape early in my career I work with
cloud now another bias is I live in the
US but I work with customers all over
the globe I guess it come another caveat
is that I recognize that there's many
different variables associated many
assumptions no two architectures are the
same two networks are the same no two
policies are the same I recognize that
upfront again this is intended to be
just sort of a dialogue and discussion
you get construct you'd have a dialogue
with your team and some things I assume
are a wash between tape and cloud so
we're not talking a lot about things
like security in this conversation so
with that let's go ahead and get started
on the economics of tape versus the
cloud as an agenda today I wanted to go
through these five things start off with
tape and cloud uses so there's good
reasons that both of these exist and now
that there's they're beginning to be
some overlap between cloud storage and
long term archival or long-term storage
I wanted to talk you know start start
the conversation off with a look at how
the two of them compare historically
second and really the heart
the conversation here is a capital and
operational costs and again wanted to
create sort of a construct as things you
should look at when looking at both the
upfront investment capital costs in the
knee ongoing cost or the operations
number three examples and tools so
hopefully I'll open up a online
calculator here where we can look at
real example of tape versus cloud and
talk a little about future
considerations and next steps so with
that let's go ahead and get started um
if if you have to drop early from this
webinar these are the key decision
drivers or the things that maybe stand
out a little bit when you're looking at
the economic considerations as we walk
through the you know the spreadsheet in
a bit these are the things you should
really think about as different sheet is
because again no two environments are
the same first durability so if you have
a high requirement for durability that
significantly impacts the economics of
tape versus cloud second personnel costs
and efficiency if you have high
personnel costs and or low efficiency or
the other way around again that's going
to significantly impact the different
differences in in the economics between
tape and cloud third data optimization
I'll talk a little bit about this
because this is one that is is usually
missed and when talking about tape
versus cloud it's what you can do to
remove redundant data to remove garbage
data to optimize the amount of data that
in fact needs to be stored for a long
period of time and then close with a
little or think a little bit about data
utility right so what's the greatest use
your getting out of that data that's
stored long term it's stored in tape or
extorting cloud so those four things
I'll go all I'll walk through I'll give
to these as we talk over the next few
minutes and wrap with it I'm at dividend
durability personnel cost data
optimization data utility so let's take
a quick step back and and reiterates or
sort of Aria revisit white ape and cloud
exist room but it's probably most of you
use tape because it's portable
it's durable it's inexpensive as cheap
and is installed already right there's a
there is a sunk cost you've got this
investment actually not just in the
hardware but also in the time it takes
to understand how to operate it so tape
exists for good reasons for to get your
data to get your your data off-site I'm
it's portable and it really works well
cloud on the other hand really came up
through a sort of the concept of
outsourcing or moving your power your
cooling your redundancy moving the
requirements of availability and a whole
bunch of other things off to somebody
else letting you focus on what you do
best right you don't need to worry about
the mechanics of our infrastructure
instead you're going to worry about
focusing on things that allow you to do
things differently differentiate
yourself now it's like it's really
important when we talk about tape and
long-term storage that we call out this
you know this classic difference between
backup and archive a lot of people
conflate the two backup really is about
recovery it's a really important
distinction it's a second or third copy
while archive is really for legal or
regulatory requirements usually or to
meet an important SLA it's it's also the
case that some people turn backups into
archives which is a cause of significant
really significant inefficiencies so as
if that is a sort of a background or a
peeker so what's getting to the heart of
this conversation the capital and
operational costs associated with the
tape and cloud so at a high level disk
tape and clouds are included disk here
if you're looking at the cost of
long-term storage this is a very just
get high level snapshot capital outlay
the winners are here in green capital
outlay cloud wins because there's
there's there's virtually no upfront
capital outlay capacity costs usually
tape wins when you just look at the cost
per terabyte or per gigabyte over a
period of time from a capacity
standpoint it's it's usually taped at
once shipping and logistics cloud wins
because there are none you don't ship
disk you don't ship tape I mean you know
ship cloud like you shipped a disk or
tape
networking costs tape wins there's
there's none or very low in fact
personnel costs is lowest with cloud or
disk because they're more automated more
direct processes and recovery costs are
low with cloud and disk as well but what
I really want to focus on here are tape
and cloud it's been a lot of
conversation on disk versus tape and now
I really want to talk a little talk
about cloud and tape so let's first go
deep on the capital upfront cost of tape
now if you use tape today hopefully this
look familiar to you the biggest upfront
cost is buying your library bar in your
autoloader this can range from 3k 250k
or into the hundreds of thousands of
dollars it could be a little bit lower i
purchased an autoloader that cost less
than that but it also could be a lot
higher I've seen libraries that run into
the hundreds of thousands of dollars
it's typically capitalized over three
years but nobody but the lifespan
typically is longer than that the the
next thing that people think about in
terms of upfront cost is tapes right you
need to buy tapes up front both for your
backup and archival and this this can
significantly vary depending on what
your backup schedules are if your
backups but but but generally you might
pay somewhere between thirty one hundred
fifty dollars I think a stream price for
an LTL six is around 30 bucks in the LTL
sevens up around hundred and thirty
hundred and forty right now under rated
for long periods of time but nobody are
very few people or very few
sophisticated people that I know
actually trust those long periods of
time long period of time you may need to
make improvements to your to your server
your networking or your San you may have
to to to make changes to your server and
maybe buy a fibre channel card things
like that in order to backup up to or
move your data to to the to a tape to a
tape device and then of course these are
physical devices that need to be shipped
they need to be unpacked and plugged in
and put in a rack then they need to be
physic
we managed up front so these are the
costs you know you have to buy the
loader you have to buy the tapes have to
make changes to your server your
networking and then you have to actually
spend some money up front to get to
things start it up generally high cost
now let's move from upfront costs I
should say for cloud I originally had
made a slide that said this DS are the
capital costs up front really the are no
capital costs up front for cloud the
capital costs up front for cloud it are
really just a learning curve it takes
and it's you it's a very very small
learning or low learning curve I'm so
let's move from capital cost upfront
costs to operational costs right or easy
your ongoing expenses in fact and let's
start with cloud and these are the
things the six things that typically you
should take into account when you think
on your ongoing cost of storing things
long-term in a cloud first ingestion of
getting the data to the cloud this is a
this is not trivial if you have
significant amounts of data you can do
it either online directly if you have
good networks or you can even do it
offline you can ship drives and have
them ingested by by third parties
storage storage is typically what people
focus on the most and rightfully so it's
by far the largest portion of your cost
but remember storages is all-inclusive
it gives you the high level of 11 9s
durability I'll talk a little bit about
in a moment with online access and on
demand and all that good stuff but that
is typically the highest cost and it'll
range anywhere from at least with with
Google and with other cloud providers
this is the general range from 22 point
6 cents down to a penny a gigabyte
operations so this is our charges for
operations in the cloud is typically not
an issue for long-term storage but I did
actually have a customer 12 at 800
million files who wanted to be kept as
separate objects in it
we charge a penny a gig Peppa sorry a
penny per 10,000 operations so it costs
800 bucks to to do the the puts on on
his his operations costs excess reads
this is something that you do need to
think about it for long term storage arm
tier that I'll talk about a minute this
near line and that's intended for
long-term storage so it has a lower cost
it's it's less than fifty percent it's
closer to about thirty percent the cost
of traditional online object storage but
it also has a cost to read the data
because it's not intended to be read
frequently and it caught it's a cost of
a penny a gig for for the reeds
networking there is an excess burden on
networking but this is really tricky
because network configurations and costs
associated with them can vary so
significantly I think it's just
important to point out that moving data
from on prend a private data center or
or private game center to the cloud for
long-term storage does have some cost
through an increased network traffic and
then finally recycle operational costs
of cloud its personnel and you're going
to find my as I mentioned early on one
of the overriding themes is that cloud
and disc for that matter give you the
ability to optimize your data to
optimize your entire corpus so you can
delete redundant data eliminate garbage
and this benefit in fact will require
some additional effort so we think about
the operational costs of cloud which is
what we're talking about on this slide
you should you should to be fair take
that into account and and there is there
will be some effort but of course at
effort will pay off many times over as
you reduce the amount of data you have
now let's move on to the operational
costs of tape and there's I've got two
slides on this the first is focused on
people and infrastructure and again
going back to what I my main themes
people you taped as a manual process
right tape requires you two up to
to manage to physically move stuff to
grab stuff to move it around and that
that takes that you know you that takes
people to do it and we look at the real
cost of tape you need to take that into
account and you need to understand how
efficient your labor is you might be
anywhere from a half a person or a
quarter of a person up two three four
five I've never seen actually one bigger
than five or six but there's also a
significant cost to restore data so you
know the question I have in italic
serious how efficient is your team and
you need to factor that in and because
it get it very so significantly and this
is a very significant piece of the drive
drivers of your ongoing operational
costs of tape there's also ongoing costs
associated with your hardware your tape
infrastructure so the the hardware
maintenance is is you know anywhere from
19 to 25 percent you also need to be
concerned with or think about tape
refresh maintenance you know you need to
think about the durability of these
tapes you know when you're going to
replace them certain tapes are going to
are going to fail also you need to think
about the compatibility as formats
change as you move from lto-4 25 26 27
28 now there's there are some real costs
associated with with that off-site
storage and transportation whether you
pay for a service like an Iron Mountain
to store your tapes in their own
protected vault or in in if you store it
in your own secure environmentally it is
not environmentally safe involve
yourself these costs are in fact real
and never-ending and then finally and
this is one of the really big themes I
mentioned at the top of this is do you
think about building a redundant or
durable infrastructure this is a really
big one that's often overlooked when
you're looking at the economics of tape
versus cloud if a high durability if
hyper ability is important to you you'll
need to engineer that and you'll need
you need to engineer a certain level of
redundancy to get that durability
they've not required
two copies or even three copies of your
data so for cloud 1190 durability comes
built in so for tape this could double
or triple the calculation to have a
similar type level of redundancy a
real-world example I called out here at
a customer who had ten north of 10
petabytes of storage of that that were
being put off on the tape they had three
Jill redundant copies they refresh the
entire corpus every five years and they
really provided a white-glove service
they did lots of testing they really
this was very important data to them and
they calculated date they paid about 4
cents per gigabyte per month to maintain
that level of durability so that's a
really important calculation as you
think through its it's the level of
redundancy or liberally level durability
target durability yet how many knives
the question I put here is you know what
would it cost you to deliver 11 9
through ability how many copies would
you have to have operational cost of
tape this is the second one I time n
sioned before optimizations this is I
really often ignored often hidden and
misunderstood costs first in any
calculation you take you take into
account the actual tape utilization it's
not typically a hundred percent second
you realize that there's a tremendous
amount of copied or redundant data that
that that needs to be or that can be
removed to call this redundant data
requires work and with data locked away
on a tape requires a lot of work so much
so that most people don't put much of an
effort into cleaning up copies a third
and related optimization that's really
hard is just removing the garbage data
if you look at some of the stats that
are on the slide you know the redundant
data there IDC claims there's 23
generally an enterprise or global 2000
companies are theirs on average 23
copies the same file and look at all the
different places that a file might
of all the different backup copies all
the archived copies all the different
file servers and it's a challenger with
the same with garbage data sectarian
came out with the the statistic that any
given 30 percent of an average
organization's data could be deleted and
so really the question there is how much
effort doesn't require to remove this
data now what's the the required effort
to to optimize that that that data all
right so with that let's move on to a
really a short discussion of a
networking I think networking is a key
thing it's just frankly just a common
question that I get asked networking
generally the question is something
along the lines of hey my network is
unreliable slow and and therefore is the
cloud right for me a few things I want
to point out here first back up an
archives typically an offline process so
they get interrupted they can continue
or that that's a second pieces they get
interrupted they can they can do resumed
it's typically built into all kinds of
software including to Google Network
throttle throttle lanes a common feature
to make sure you don't consume your
network local caching or to a series of
disk arrays j-bot is effective and sheep
and dr in the cloud mitigates many of
these concerns so if you are going to
recover to the cloud then that's a
really important way to avoid having
lots of data back on prep and the last
thing i'll say on this is you know that
your network can really be a problem but
networking speeds access reliability
they're they're improving all the time
and so it might not be the right time
for you now to move to the cloud but it
you know keep an eye on it because this
is something that's important to Google
and something important to a lot of
government institutions a lot of
government entity
these speeds aren't proof okay so with
that I wanted to move to a real
calculation a real or example I guess a
calculation so let me go ahead and move
over to an online calculator that we
created and this is really just a
back-of-the-envelope calculator the
things in yellow are the things that can
in fact our cells that can be changed
based upon the assumptions that we just
talked about and it'll calculate out for
you here the annual cost of cloud and
the annual cost of tape and what I did
was I determined the annual cost based
upon multiple multiple years so I made
the assumption i'm here a number of
years on tape you get the amount of data
up here you got the minimum number of
copies again going back to the web to
level of durability you expected how
many copies likely are going to need all
in copies then i mean again over here
the key assumptions are your cost your
tape library I took a cost of a dell ml
6010 library the capitalization period
of it I use is three years on the cost
of IP staff you'll find is as you look
at this a significant driver so you know
I started with a 90,000 number and then
what's the percentage of time spent on
managing that taped infrastructure and
number of restore per month and then
this last one is really interesting it's
the what what likely optimization can
you get of that 500 terabytes or of that
data that you have up here in cell b3
what percentage of that you think you
can optimize if you had easy access to
it right so this is the if I can go back
and find those 23 copies that IDC says
an average enterprise has or if I can go
and find the thirty percent of data that
can be that's just junk and it can be
deleted you know what's what kind of
optimization can you get because again
doing it and tapes not impossible it
really isn't that's really hard right
it's really it's just it's just it's
almost again we talked to talk to folks
who do this that
just almost not worth putting a lot of
effort into finding all that all the
duplicate data and all that garbage data
so as I go through you know the
assumptions over here on the right-hand
side the cost of cloud we've got the
capacity the operations and networking
in the reeds and and as you work through
this will be online in a prettier format
after the webinar but today if you
change and say your cost of of an IT
staff fully loaded IT staff is 70,000
you see how it changes you know right
now it's it's sixty seven thousand
dollars a year to protect that 500
terabytes if you go up and you say you
know what I can withstand lower I have a
lower durability threshold maybe only
one copy that brings down your cost
let's say costume I tape libraries only
25,000 that changing you can see how
that changes the cost let's say somebody
actually uses seventy percent at the
states or even let's say it one hundred
percent 14 / two dedicated to doing this
you can see how about how your average
changes your average cost the cost per
year change of course you can go back
here and change the amount of data so
it's if it's let's say it's a decimal
petabyte and we need two copies but you
can see the differences here the
important to figure out and the
optimizations again it's at thirty
percent I think this is one of the
really key assumptions if you can get
seventy percent it can dramatically
essentially lower the cost of cloud
because you've removed a big part of
your petabyte corpus that you need to
store on tape and if you think that
you're going to get a very small
percentage you can see how much that
increases the cost to keeping it in
clogged you can see down here the sort
of the cost assumptions i use street
price for LT 07 versus lto-6 and this is
again a tool that can be made available
online after this webinar so it's going
to go back and wrap up this conversation
with some future considerations and next
steps we've talked a lot about how we
get me talked about cloud and what they
were intended for we went in tried to I
think look at
real world examples of cost associated
with each but I did want to talk a
little bit about the future of sort of
changing hot changing expectations and
changing technologies so cloud offers
declining costs right on an ongoing
basis you'll see over a period of time
and I probably should have included this
in this conversation but there's there's
declining class and cloud as soon as the
cost to us or suit or two to the
industry hit typically they get passed
on some relatively quick period of time
to to the end user to you to the
consumer of the cloud which is to say
very different than a capital outlay
right not very many hardware
manufacturers go back to you six months
after their cost to come down and say
hey here's your money back because
because you've at that point obviously
purchased at that hardware so you have
declining costs and you have increasing
utility and what we haven't talked about
was the increase in utility and what do
I mean by that it's basically just do
more with the data more easily right so
you have lots of data it gets put off on
these tape drives and the potential
value of this data is is locked away
it's really hard to get to so you if you
had that in the cloud we had that online
you can do things like analytics we have
got a product that does that called big
BBQ image analysis text and language
analysis we've got a vision API and our
natural language api that are services
that you can leverage you can lay
against the data that's stored online
but even more broadly than that you can
have commingled services from other
cloud providers right we live in this
api world where you if you had access to
your long-term store data you can then
do think you can create new businesses
you can create new revenue streams you
can leverage that long tail of data that
in ways you perhaps couldn't in the past
so even just you know again it's really
hard because we're talking about the
economic considerations of cloud versus
tape but even
if you if you just think about the
possibilities of what you can do your
didya if you had a globally available
globally accessible at a very low cost
you know that's when you really it
really starts to get exciting that's
when it really changes the economics of
of cloud vs vs tape so i did want to
finish just with a quick introduction to
our services to our product it's called
google cloud storage this is our object
stores is our blobstore and allows you
to store access and manage unstructured
data on our infrastructure and the key
things are it gives you unlimited scale
global availability high durability 11
90 bility as we talked about and low
cost and we have three tiers of storage
our standard our durable reduced
availability and near line storage near
lines the one that I've been talking
about primarily throughout this that's a
penny a gig perma with penny the cost
the to read at a penny a gigabyte its
high-speed it's again highly highly
durable it's 11 9 durability and it's
low cost I did want to you know I get
asked us all the time well how's your
cloud different and I wanted to call out
just a handful of things and you should
you you could sit through an entire
presentation on our differentiators but
didn't talk about our massive
scalability you'll never run out of
capacity when using us our global
network you know we've laid fiber we've
laid cables across the oceans its
strategic to us to be able to get data
and keep data on our network as long as
possible because we're highly efficient
with it I'm that translate into more
predictable performance of the network
when you're using our infrastructure
we've got low pricing we're proud of the
fact that we lead the industry in
pricing and will continue to do that
we've got these interesting cloud
service as I mentioned before things
like machine learning and data analytics
and search that you can leverage against
your data we have a single API and this
is a real distinction between us and
other cloud services you don't need to
have you don't need to write your data
for for primary or 44
your standard storage in one way and
writing in a separate way for your
archive storage right across all of our
tears of storage it's the same single
set of a single API and then we've got
tight integration I say tight
integration that's really with you know
backup and archive vendors right we
don't we are not an archiving vendor
ourselves right we work with partners we
work with companies like Veritas with
commvault and who have on-prem backup
and archiving software so at the top of
this conversation I I talked about the
critical decision points right let's
circle back to these and and and I
really wanted to drive home these points
as you look at the online calculator and
think about the cost of cloud and the
cost of tape first is durability right
if you can if you require a required to
have high level durability right then
you're going to likely end up having to
engineer that yourself across
potentially multiple copies the
personnel costs are high rather your
personal cost if they're high and if
your efficiency is low then then it's
it's going to impact the decision
between cloud and tape and again it's
because tape is a such a manual process
data optimization in the more day Thomas
optimization you think you can do when
you have access and availability to your
cloud then the more the the benefits of
cloud will become reality and then this
data utility or this piece of you know
boy if I had access to my data what new
and interesting businesses could I build
what new interesting services could I
build you know how can I get more value
from my data that you know again with
cloud you you have access to it you can
do it and we tape you simply can't so
durability personnel how much data
ization you can do and your data utility
so with that I wanted to just close with
some some next steps and and you know I
really think as you keep movie it's
great that you're attending this webinar
contact us for the online calculator it
will make it available it's again it's
not perfect love your feedback but I'd
want to be able to make sure that or I
do want to make that available as a is a
tool for you and making the decisions
read recently published iesg white paper
on data protection to the cloud i watch
our other videos in this series it's a I
think all three of these things are at
cloud google.com / meant storage we have
a promotional credit running right now
three hundred dollars and with that
three hundred dollars I strongly
recommend i always say this to folks
experiment experiment experiment right
try try try this is do the beauty of
cloud right there is there is no huge
upfront cost other than your time and
your time can help you determine whether
this makes sense or not so thank you
again this was a great opportunity
hopefully you found some value in this I
do want to i'll go ahead and stop
sharing right here i do you want to
thank you for your time on this this is
i think is it hopefully will give you
some things to consider you will have a
tool that tool available I've got the
white paper available recommend go ahead
and playing with with the cloud storage
it's an easy thing to learn it's a
low-cost again we have a three-under
dollar credit running right now thanks
so much for your time and look forward
to to working with with you to help you
learn a little bit more about cloud and
have a comparison tape thanks
you